le italiano ha fatto 46 secondi a capo a
flavio un minuto 30 ailog mark player un
minuto e 44 bene io non sono anche di
che cazzo di gioco si tratta quindi a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su scoot
scoop che sarebbe un videogame che non
ho capito però credo che scoop si
riferisca allo scooter panzone anche
come cazzo si gioca cosa debba fare però
già visto che ci sono i scoreboard dove
il primo si chiama le italiano portiamo
in alto la bandiera italiana anche sui
videogames gamepad recommended significa
che i gamepad sono raccomandati credo
erano lo aspetta un attimo un attimo sto
srotolando il pene come faccio e vabbè
quello già fatti può già finito mi sono
già tutti a casa a godersi del buon vino
il video sono ancora qua sono un attimo
mi fate di partire per cortesia ed eva e
vari file epub grazie gentilissimo
veramente sei un cuore come faccio set
dall non devo prendere cose che bene non
devo prendere va bene il mio obiettivo
sarebbe quello di via di morire
probabilmente di morire devo devo fare
il giro quindi ho capito ha più 0 25
quindi ogni cosa che buttò giù mi dà una
penalità di tempo ok avevo capito il mio
obiettivo è sono eh va beh allora il mio
obiettivo quale è quello di arrivare
fino alla fine in tutto intero 123 a di
quadrato o sbagliato pure strada
fantastico mango la strada giusta
ragazzi un idiota fantastico vai così
vai vai veloce zio perfetto no tutto
storto sei bravissimo michele anche in
turbo dismount così bravo c'è un motivo
se ancora mandata la patente cercate di
capire qual è chi lo capisce per primo
vince la rotonda va presa in senso
antiorario no cazzo che bravi snow zio
bravo che no anche quante volte devo
fare il giro si richia 3 pigliati cosa
sta epa sei scema quanti problemi cha
sto motorino il problema non è neanche
quanto punteggio fa i premi arrivare
alla fine io arrivo manco a fine effetto
perfetto vai vai vai
vai vai sì certo neanche di arrivare
alla fine dichiara e di quanto tutti se
faceva una gara per buttarli giù vorrà
veramente sarei riuscito a vincere a
quest'ora mi chiede anche a provarci o
cosa ho fatto giri c'è l'obiettivo in
teoria sarebbe quello di andare liscio
fino alla fine in india non riesco a fan
m destra io non vedo poi la telecamera
non vedo un cazzo perché ci sono gli
alberi di mama alzati ma come ho fatto a
morire
ragazzi se mi vedete per caso in giro
con una macchina prima o poi scappa tema
veloce ma forte contante che chi aveva
battuto il record in casa fatto scema
come non doveva non doveva mai uscire
una roba del genere mia ho avuto un cul
incredibile non posso avere del tempo in
più per questa cosa che ho fatto no vero
ma perché mi chiara una cosa troppo fico
ma darò fatto non so guidare per niente
perfetto perfetto
pensate che il primo riuscirò a finire
una frase senza fare un trick shot il
primo in classifica quello che ho visto
che arrivato primo le italiano ha fatto
tipo 41 secondi io sono minute 23 41
secondi facendo tutti i giri ce l'hanno
fatto ancora neanche uno solo per dirvi
bra la zia complimenti magari riesce a
centrare il buco anche se quello il
compito dell'uomo bravissima fantastico
bye bye bye bye bye skins us china zio
schino skin maschi maschi maschi ma
veloce però quanto faccio schifo guidare
madonna ma sei scema allora porca eva
quanto è indemoniato questo motorino
spiegatemi mi fate capire narrava c'è
solo suo livello non posso farne altri
perché questo è veramente un casino è
perfetto perfetto fede
quali problemi al cervello possiedi
spiega amico ha fatta fare 46 secondi
quanto è un mutante sto tizio non potete
cambiare livello vi supplico mica gaza
in glory la copia di epix in 3d ebbe più
completo come gioco grazie palo ce n'era
uno è bravo se non ci fosse sta
musicando veramente cagare a spruzzo il
timpani sarebbe fantastico poi prova a
rimediare alla roba della musica ragazzi
però fatemi finire il circuito prima
michia valentino rossi sarebbe fiero di
me ci vorrebbe guido meda a commentare
questa cosa ragazze ci prova valentino
questa staccata passa indenne o mamma
mia
amir dan a guido si dice così si dice
porca di quella eva mi sta dando la
testa la musica fermi mettiamo della
musica che scelgo io prova a indovinare
quale sceglierò stavolta il madonna sia
ma sei veramente una monco poetica
barabara monese ei papà galli quei fatti
ea browse il palo in pieno sia
complimentava brava m'incazzo marin ex
dei pop up pa pa pa pa ra barca e vale
già visto cosv e nervi bagno di stelle
che sono facendo abbastanza un punteggio
era vai questa canzone concentra mai vai
veloce
minchia valentino valentino al chilo e
dino rossi c'è
porca eva l'ho presa male the way wire
ruolo non è vero in ex dei barbapapà
para va bene ragazzi record record
record di singolo giro
un minuto e 11 fa vj facendo weil
superato così avanti velocissimo 2 17 2
17 manca l'ultimo giro non ci posso
credere devo essere tranquillo perché
sennò mi chiami mi distraggo per il
fermo che non portano cagate su youtube
perché partono i video da solito noi
parte una canzone a casa dicono in parte
nek o no grazie a dio ripartita un'altra
tac story
ragioneremo nei tre dai chebanca
all'ultimo giro veloce
vai vai vai vai non chiedere se non ci
sarà un pezzo di merda a troja ha dato
la patente feccia della strada chi te
l'ha data ma [ __ ] terra lemonade
al terzo giro non ho parole
al terzo giro miei amici mi fanno i like
gummy bear va bene va bene va bene ora
macchia mib
ahia ahia ahia fugge pachinese quindi è
appunto ed affini ed andrea houllier oa
brava ti sta bene [ __ ] senza mani senza
mani senza mani e salacca questa nave
carica quest'anno dalla carica bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye nodi la porco
demonio
porco ma para para papa dove cazzo siete
pronti ragazzi queste serie a chiudete
la porta di casa non fate ascoltare i
vostri genitori che questa è molto
pesante
ci siete
[Musica]
arriva infatti già
e non tu però sei l'ultimo giro
all'ultimo giro cugino giro sto suonando
questa parte difficile
l'ho detto organi ma ce l'ha fatta sua
mente quello che ranieri sempre piedi
brava brava zia brava piano piano piano
prepagato il piano piano come sono teso
pane anche nell'incontro di goku contro
veggente ero così attento
[Musica]
ho vinto unità quanto tempo per vincere
03 31 ma chi era qua bene come record va
bene smith
c'è una classifica da vedere o il mio
punteggio l'hai preso lei buttato nel
cesso di dirgli di non so dove voi mi
spiegate come questo cristiano come
cazzo ha fatto sto cristiana a fare 00
46 fra i giri in 46 secondi va bene così
sono contento secondo voi faccio stato
mandasse faccio vedere questo video
quelli della motorizzazione che
dovrebbero darmi la patente me la danno
senza fare il test cioè sono a posto no
che è difficile sta roba dovrebbe valere
qualcosa spero come ragazzi spero che
vide vi sia piaciuto e sta visto sudando
dio mio è stato difficilissimo
chiaramente neanche le verifiche di
matematica non così difficili spero che
vi sia piaciuto conclude episodi ragazzi
cosa che mi è piaciuta sull'argomento è
un mi piace anche la pace di facebook e
cavani video totale descrizione
sensoristica 10 picchiavano prossimo
visto le ragazze